bene tutti ragazze prossimo video sono
fa vigenti siamo sul nuovo video di
dredd out nuovi episodi avendo dei
problemi ultimamente nel dire le cose
sto invecchiando con creazioni maschi
che c'era dove cazzo è la tipa bella che
se la ritrova la sposo ragazzi erano
rimasti che stati boagno chi si ma
perché veramente ignote a vederla è
veramente [ __ ] avete presente quando una
ragazza strana oca si strucca e questo
ragazzi vi insegna non stare non credere
che le ragazze truccate siano belle
perché non è così
vabbè scia degli insegnamenti questo
gioco mi fa piacere non mi toccare
l'unico partito stronzo bravo ascolta
fattiva di fare aprile che mi manca
aprile perfetto questo aprile giugno
che cosa ho fatto ho colpito merda è
vera se un pervertito del cazzo però è
l'occhio cazzo grande vai così muori
no non tu lui muore bravo strano sabbi
paura di fare buongiorno a e la corsa
col sacco lo che la conosco sta cosa ci
giocava da piccola
[Musica]
questa è una corsa col sacco con tanto
di testate pertanto zio
se mi tocchi un'altra volta giuro che
parte la denuncia ma secca proprio
bastardi qualche altra via che botto
tanto in posa bravi così voi vi voglio
più sexy più più performanti perfetto
ancora una ancora una ok bene perché
siete pronte amica sexy dove sei e mi
guarda mi manca ogni volta di più con
tutto l'amore che ho nei suoi confronti
ho vinto soca stronza stavo scherzando
zia o se vuoi ti faccio un'altra foto mi
ha stretto anche mangiato pesante a
pranzo credo cazzo sta succedendo che
cazzo è quella per mentre sfruttato
notizia era spuntato nati cosa sta
succedendo in questo stato
li mortacci tua la tipa un po meno mi
sono mora e belli lei è in grado di
sedurre con lo sguardo di roma sono
morto proprio a così a caso è stata la
cosa più bella della mia zia se lo vuoi
un po più lungo basta chiedere che
arrivò ok era pessima era pessima alla
pessima segniamo cioè nella pessima con
ragazzi a parte sta roba che è successo
perché si dove cazzo son finito
regalistica chi sta piangendo da un'ora
e mezza spiegatemelo c'è nessuno
[Musica]
buongiorno ma salve signor a una bambina
ciao consiglio del make up dico la tizia
di prima 3d sei molto bella posso farti
una foto con un conto è sexy
ti faccio una foto o donna credevo mi
salta addosso era una bambina che
piangeva prima sì qualcuno comunque mi
deve spiegare il senso di questo gioco
perché ancora non lo sto capendo vabbè
in cinque minuti dai cazzo successo che
ho battuto
e che cazzo però quanta gente che piange
c'è in questo gioco farmi capire
devo trovare un'altra ragazza che piange
oggi è la giornata delle ragazze che
piangono stava bene ma chi è che sta
piangendo filmato filmato grazie a dio
un sacco un sacco che piange
non sa è una ragazza dentro un sacco che
piange ma piange perché il sacco e
brutto il sacco piange perché tu sei
brutta il sacco piange perché tu sei
brutta questa mi chiara quella del primo
episodio ancora ecco perché mi conosce
mi che fatti non stavo capendo che dove
sono tutti gli altri si masi appalto
anni di meno che denuncio pure terra che
è successo mi ha sentito rumori brutti
bene ce l'abbiamo già nel bur neanche
tempo un minuto di far chiacchiere che
già perfetto mamma sei tu non è mamma
che si scaricherà lei se stiamo
ricongiungendo tutti nello stesso
momento dato lei è morto bene
complimenti
l'utilità che hai avuto in questo gioco
zia complimenti cioè ascolta zia
rialzata ha già tutto a posto in teoria
cosa ti ha morso al collo un ghepardo
shamo perché non ho capito dove dobbiamo
andare adesso c'è stato bello ritrovare
quella della tizia di prima il giuro
però salve anche a lei non è normale
vedere una ragazza che sta a fissare i
pali così ti faccio una foto da lontano
te ne faccio un'altra semi caghi magari
è meglio
ok è scappato non ragazzo vai dove cazzo
mai con quel bel culetto doveva ieni
qualche fraternizza vola prove persone
vieni a [ __ ]
ecco ciò che adesso questa lamento su
facebook e ti tagua e basta però che
cazzo
[Musica]
ascoltati anzi ho fotografato anche
prima se ti va bene se ti fotografa ma
ti dovresti andare in teoria ok ok sono
solo vivo ma se non sempre conoscenza
che faccio e non si sa mai ma chi è
questa
no basta correre rotto il cazzo ma dopo
e non bassone tolo tv in testa negli
uffici a mike eseguendo persona in
edizione cazzo andata lega cioè ti sei
nascosta nel televisore nelle banche
dove cazzo è c'è una porta che si apre
sia se qua a sei bella la bambola
ascolta zia mimi sta bene che lasci le
scarpe fuori per non sporcare ma tanto è
tutto lercio per terra cazzo
dovevo chiudere la porta prima sono duri
da [ __ ] sei stata già i poteri
paranormali mi allontana le sedie st
zocco senti zia e non lo facciamo più
che è limitare avere i tuoi poteri
paranormali su altre persone otto anni
caduto il telefono samantha cosa cazzo
c'è scritto ma vai a batteria cosa
saranno scaricate le pile prima famiglia
chi sei tu ciao era però tu non sei
rocchi
ciao susy me ne vado basta così
e stato bello io tra queste due domande
non so quale potrei fare tra hai ucciso
i miei amici o stupida bambola non so
quale delle due sia peggio stupida
bambola non voglio vederlo numeri ma non
voglio vederlo non voglio vederlo
voglio vederlo cosa stai facendo
lo sapevo ci avrei scommesso che sarebbe
successa da cagata del genere però che è
stata la conversazione più vigna che
abbia mai avuto in tutta la mia vita con
una strana o cavour o trovato la chiave
di una maggiore
[Applauso]
ma non è così che nascono i bambini
mamma mi ha mentito maledizione che cosa
cazzo era quella roba lì tutto [ __ ]
cos'è che regga lega che cosa scusa o
mio dio siete la cosa più bella che
abbia mai visto via veramente fammi
tornare dovrò prima di montarci lo posso
tutelare nel furgone
no è chiusa bene ho sperato fino
all'ultimo ragazze voi non avete non
avete idea di cosa ho visto ragazze non
potete capire ragazze siete ancora qui
spiega un cellulare ma come dove chiasso
sono finite le tipe no no no no non
dimmi che sono crepati sono attaccato al
soffitto perché hai fatto con lo sguardo
non si possono creare ma come vada ma
chi è ma chi è stato non mi posso
allontanare cinque minuti che dica che
depressione non ti sperare così via dai
succede succede a tutti in vita se
magari mi stordisce di meno costretto
rombi di merda capisco che un gioco del
genere queste trombe di merda possano
portare all'esasperazione però mio dio
perché ci sono delle teste che stanno
rotolandosi dalle scale non spiegate
legati tra l'altro una e sexyssima posso
giocare a calcio col test per l'iss
giorno ha permesso sono fa vj entro
archivio anche la porta che sono un
gentleman che la madonna mi chiamo anche
una partita di calcio ci fa in sto
corridoio lo so che fa vomitare la casa
sia ma non c'è bisogno di sentire tra
così tua c'è uno stato di mortacci che
mi son cagato addosso
ecco l'ho visto ho forti a [ __ ] quanto
sembrano stabili un bravo togliti la
casa tagli che ecco vedi quanto sei
brutto non vi è che gli sprechi cazzo
sta succedendo ragazzi camminando senza
muovere legale impossibile ma che bella
tavola è tutto per me è la madonna lega
ma non doveva ad accogliermi così bene
addirittura molto bella soprattutto deve
andare tra l'altro non lo so beh certo
ragazzi concludo che l'episodio è stato
e quanto strano questo episodio in
particolare è successo di tutti non so
quanto tempo ma va bene quindi ragazzi
l'ho già detto conclude male giocare
agli horror sei video è piaciuto me sei
piaciuto questo mi piace anche la voce
di facebook e come negli la tratta una
descrizione se volessi discrete il cv
con un prossimo video delle ragazze